nous sommes à la prison de devo tôt à
buenos aires
ces images ont été tournées par un
détenu on y voit un bâtiment insalubre
délit à 40 cm de distance l'un de
l'autre et des salles communes surpeuplé
dans un entretien avec art et alejandro
guevara à l'origine de cette vidéo
alerte sur les risques sanitaires qu'ils
encourent en pleine pandémie
je souffre d'asthme et d'une maladie
pulmonaire obstructive chronique parce
que je fume contaminée par le
coronavirus je serais mort en moins de
24 heures
alejandro qui purge des derniers mois
d'une peine de 24 ans a demandé une
assignation à résidence qui a été
rejetée depuis le début de la
propagation du virus
plusieurs instances judiciaires ont
recommandé de remplacer les peines de
prison par des mesures alternatives
en vain les conséquences de cette sourde
oreille pourraient être dramatiques
selon certains experts
si le problème de la surpopulation
carcérale demeure il entraînera des
problèmes sanitaires
nous constatons une situation déjà
problématique au pérou en colombie et
dans certaines prisons américaines dont
les trois quarts des détenus sont
malades
si le virus se propage parmi les
prisonniers ici également
cela entraînera une crise dans les
hôpitaux la population générale doit
être soigné selon le ministère de la
santé argentin seuls 2% de l'ensemble
des détenus des prisons fédérales ont
été placés en résidence surveillée en
raison des risques sanitaires
bien que faible ce pourcentage est jugée
inacceptable par les défenseurs des
droits des victimes et ce alors
tellement groupe italien camfin kenema
c'est complètement injuste c'est une
décision très difficile à vivre je pense
que les autorités devrait abroger ces
mesures et rendre un peu plus justice
aux victimes qui ont vécu toutes ces
horreurs ce sera à nous de veiller dans
les années à venir à ce que les
criminels qui tuent violent enlève nos
enfants purgé leur peine comme il se
doit ces dernières semaines plusieurs
organisations internationales ont
qualifiée d'alarmante la situation
carcérale en amérique latine notamment
au brésil en colombie et au pérou
en réponse à ces inquiétudes les
autorités argentines ont promis de créer
des places supplémentaires dans les
prisons et des centres de détention
provisoire